hello everyone and welcome back to the
last match of the quarterfinals of the
speed chase Championship it is Wesley
still vs Maxim Rachelle lagrava and uh
this match was much much closer than the
one between Magnus and Fabi and uh
what's what's interesting is that the
winner of this match will face Magnus
Carlsen in the semi-finals of the speed
Chess Championship and this is one game
I chose from the five plus one section
if you have any of your favorites from
maybe the the three plus one or maybe
even the bullet if it's a nice game I I
will consider it uh do you use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over it
um just give me a second I can see the
board is a little
uh
uh the board is not where it should be
uh so just give me one second there we
go
yeah for some reason for some reason
sometimes the interface just shifts and
I don't pick up on it and then it lasts
like for a few videos but then I see
someone in the comments mentioning it
and then I I realize what's happening uh
but okay let's check it out features a
very nice Sicilian Defense and whenever
we have a mvl at wielding the black
pieces then you know it's going to be a
great Sicilian uh win or lose so Wesley
with the white pieces opens with E4 we
have C5 mvl goes for the Sicilian
Defense Knight to F3 D6 and pawn to D4
we have uh C captures on D4 uh capturing
um the pawn Knight captures Knight to F6
and Knight to C3 and as usual mvl goes
for the Knight of Sicilian Ponte A6
which you can attack many many different
ways pretty much any movie in this
position is a good move for white and uh
West ghost for brush after E3 it's the
uh English attack or the Bayern attack
and we haven't had that in quite some
time so let's check it out E5 D6 are the
top moves here E5 being the most played
one just dislodging this Knight but a
maxim goes for the uh well for the uh
maybe nicest idea when it comes to Blitz
chess and that is Knight to G4 you start
harassing the bishop and then you're
gonna further harass it with the H6 G5
and the very natural moves come to mind
for black so Bishop to G5 of course you
don't want to allow Knight captures on
E3 H6 Bishop to H4 G5 and now Bishop to
G3 we have Bishop to G7 uh putting
pressure on the Knight here and just
Queen to D2 preparing the castle Queen
side Knight to B3 uh sorry Knight to C6
first attacking the Knight Knight the B3
this is all uh top Theory and now Knight
G2 E5 now this Knight is beautifully
placed on this Central Square we have H4
G4 and now Queen side Castles by Wesley
and there are some games where B5 was
played but here Maxim goes for Bishop to
E6 and it is now as of move 13 that we
have a completely new game
so Maxine probably knows all of this
says this is uh his territory B5 uh like
I said has been played before Bishop T6
is a new move and even though uh the
engine says B5 is the the top engine
move uh mvl probably thinks that Wesley
knows this as well so he tries the the
second best move maybe it will confuse
Wesley a little bit and okay Knight to
D5 this is a standard Square for this
Knight in yeah In the Sicilian Rook the
C8 and the now King to B1 I will be very
useful to get the King off of this
diagonal and if the black queen ever
finds her way to A5 you also want the A2
Pawn to be defended so here Pawn to B5
mvl starts his expansion on the queen
side and pawn to see not C four Pawn to
c three Pawn to C4 would be a terrible
move uh now it defends against this
Knight also the bishop is not as strong
and now uh or it's it it's a it's a good
move all in all so Knights the C4 are
attacking the queen putting pressure on
the B2 pawn and saying okay if you wanna
keep the queen on the board or rather
not not trade Bishop for the Knight you
have to move the queen somewhere either
to C1 or to C2 or maybe E1 but Wesley
decided as this is a five plus one Blitz
it's better to get rid of this Knight as
in Blitz or or you know pretty much
always but in Blitz Knights are very
tricky bastards so Bishop captures on
c4b captures and now Knight to C1 Rook
to B8 and now you can already see all
the pressure that um uh maxims the
bishop and Rook are pulling off to that
white Queen side uh F4 by Wesley and now
uh we have G captures on F3 and this is
one of those uh moments before Wesley
plays F4 uh he thinks and whenever you
have a position like this you you're
always thinking to yourself if you're
playing with the black pieces here
you're thinking if white plays G4 I'm
just gonna capture f g captures and F or
Alpha Song and that's exactly what the
player with the white species is
thinking and that's exactly what
happened here F F4 and G captures an F
or Alpha but Wesley missed the orator
Maxine missed um a very nice winning
idea here and that is Queen to A5
without touching the pawns uh because
there's uh not all that much you can
play now because Bishop captures on C3
is a huge threat you will not be able to
uh to pick it up uh of course you will
first eliminate the Knight remove one of
the Defenders of the C3 Pawn so let's
say Knight to E2 adding a Defender to
the C3 Pawn but it doesn't matter now we
will play Pawn to F5 and now of course
if captures then uh the the bishop will
be able to capture with um with the
delivering a check and of course if
Knight the E3 just adding another
Defender then you will castle and your
position will be spectacular here but
okay not easy to pick up in a five plus
one game so G captures an F3 by Maxim G
captures on F3 and now Queen to A5 but
now it's a little bit different because
now Knight the A2 can nicely be played
now phone to F5 doesn't really do
anything as the pawn is on F3 it's not
on F4 so here Knight the E5 and here
Wesley says all right let's get rid of
that Knight Bishop captures Bishop
captures and pawn to F4 now uh instead
of this Pawn to F4 I will mention Knight
to E3 because it's um very nice move for
white point is that after black plays
something uh it's easy to see that black
is very quickly without any moves you
will play Rook to G1 doesn't matter if
you trade or if you go back captures
captures let's say King f8 stopping Rook
to G8 now F4 and okay version of G7 King
to A1 uh Black's position is just
terrible uh you will never break through
here uh the Knight nicely guards the the
C3 Pawn you have all of this expansion
and The Rook here and the queen here
aren't really doing all that much and
the bishop blocked by his own C4 Pawn uh
is terrible so this would uh objectively
be completely winning for white but
again it's a very very hard to pick up
on such things in a in a Blitz game so
the immediate F4 by Wesley we have
Bishop captures on d5e captures on D5
and now this should be back to F6 Queen
to C2 and now Rook to G8 now grabbing
that semi-open g file King to A1 getting
rid of the king from the B file and now
King to D7 uh developing the king sword
of connecting Rooks and now comes Knight
the D4 now here the the way to play this
is maybe Queen to F5 check and then
after the king moves now you centralize
and you uh hold you just hold and the
nothing bad can happen to you however
Wesley played Knights the D4 here and he
probably didn't uh blunder the the D5
Pawn he probably wanted to sacrifice it
for activity but it doesn't really work
out in his favor Queen captures on D5
was played by Maxime Rook H to E1 and
now comes Rook to B6 and this is the
move that Wesley probably didn't take
into consideration his idea was that if
Rook the G2 attacking the White Queen as
the black queen defends The Rook uh he
he had Queen A4 check in mind and then
everything is perfectly fine for example
if King to C7 you can even play Knight
to the E6 check and you pick up the
black queen okay uh black is not lost or
anything black will again some material
for for the queen but it's okay Queen 5
check this one is hanging this Pawn is
saying The Rook is nicely placed on the
file it's a it's a fine position
but Maxine played uh Rook the B6 instead
and now he's uh he he gains more control
over that C6 square that Wesley will try
to take advantage of uh so weekly plays
Knight the F5 here and this move
completely blunders the game for Wesley
so feel free to pause the video now and
try to calculate why this is so while I
give you a couple of seconds it's quite
a quite a nice maneuver
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting that
it's the move that we already tried only
in this position it now works and for
those of you who just won't enjoy the
show it is Rook to G2 uh this is what
Maxine played and he was in this
position on move 29 uh that Wesley so
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it's uh the problem
behind The Rook to G2 is that now uh the
queen cannot uh just do nothing and
defend against The Rook plus the B2 Pawn
will be under attack plus the queen has
to remain on this diagonal to defend the
Knight so Knight to F5 uh that's
basically the blunder and I will just
show you a couple of uh really fun lines
okay what happens if we trade Queens
Rook captures Rook captures on C2 uh how
do you play this the the B2 Pawn is
hanging if you play Rook to B1 then it's
just a very nice Checkmate Rook B
captures on B2 check Rook captures The
Rook to C1 check only move Rook to B1
and now Bishop characters and C 3 will
be Checkmate so after this will captures
on C2 you can't really play Rook to B1
you have to play something but what if
you play Knight to D4 uh it's it's uh
it's one possibility but still just Rook
C captures on B2 and this will now be a
problem to give you uh maybe a nice line
Rook to C1 you want to defend on C3 E6
attacks the rook and after The Rook
moves now you just pick up the Knight
and create a pass Pawn you're gonna push
it to C3 white cannot capture because of
Checkmate on B1 and whatever you play
doesn't really matter you're gonna play
C2 and now there is no defense against
uh Rook to B1 check this will be
Checkmate or you can play Rook to B3
defend mate this way but then okay we
just capture Rook captures a captures
and now Rook the B1 check you can even
go into a king and pawn end game and
this is now completely winning for black
if you if you're new to chess uh upon up
in uh mostly every situation uh in in a
king and one end game will win you the
game there are of course positions where
it will not but more often than not it
it will so that's one of the reasons if
you have to Rook the G2 you just go for
for a nice Queen trade uh instead of
this you could go for well there it's
it's a very hard to to find a reasonable
move you could block maybe Rook to E2
that's a possibility but then you just
trade Rook captures and now the queen
can no longer defend the Knight
um or or if you go Rook captures on D5
uh then just throw captures on C2 you
are now up a full Rook or if you capture
The Rook here then just Queen captures
and F5 you are now again up up a full
Bishop so whatever you do yeah it
doesn't really uh it doesn't really work
the only thing you could do is maybe
play Knight captures on E7 uh but after
Bishop captures uh I mean okay you you
gave up a piece and now you're gonna try
something but still what do you want to
play Queen to B1
and it's uh it's a silly position Rook
the D2 it's pointless to play being down
a piece of course you guys know this but
just in case anyone is interested uh so
yeah after Rook the G2 Wesley doesn't
want to look at this game any anymore
and of course it was in this position
that he resigned the game and what
happened in the during the entire match
well here are the uh results of every
time uh time control in the five plus
one Maxine vashilograph one with a
result of six to three then Wesley won
the three plus one section with a result
of uh five to four so he bonds back a
little bit he was down by only two
points and during uh the bullets the
bullet section he even equalized at some
point he was down four points then he
equalized the result was 10 10 but in
the end Maxime uh got a winning streak
and he he won like four games in a row
and in the end the result was 16 and a
half to 12
um and a half so sort of equalish but in
the end Maxime was better especially in
that five plus one format that was uh
uh there he was just much better also in
bullied but Wesley won the three plus
one section and what does this mean uh
like we said the winner the prize for
winning this match is uh playing against
Magnus Carlsen in the semi-finals of the
speeches Championship uh this is uh
sorry this is what's happening so you
have uh uh Nakamura will face nihal
sarin in the semi-final and now we know
that Magnus Carlsen will face Maxim
vashiella grav uh and then we'll see uh
we'll see who will meet um uh in the in
the finals of the speed chess
championship of course everyone is
rooting for for for Magnus and Hikaru
but nihal uh really just crushed
everyone he played so we'll see if if he
will be able to uh do something against
Hikaru uh you know it's gonna be a great
match uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and a little bit of
extra info on the side I would like to
thank Timothy Rosa and Chris Robert
Picard sapan Bhatia Sarah Hamilton and
Jonathan Hiroshi foreign mission to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day